A lot of people who, I think will relate to this song...
...are people who are dealing with not ever really feeling cool with themselves...
...because other people make them feel like they don't fit in.
One thing I learned in this whole process is,...
...is you can get everything you want in life without ever feeling like you fit in.
Selling millions of records doesn't make me feel cool, it makes me feel proud...
...and I have a lot of people on my side and I've worked really hard but...
...I don't think it's the most important thing in life to fit in.
I think it's the most important thing in life to dance to the beat of your own drum...
...and to look like you're having more fun than the people who look cool like they fit in.